wish you a merry christmas we wish you a
merry christmas
up and down the country christmas is
different
what are we gonna do with these for the
people staying at home
hi merry christmas everyone and those
planning a quiet christmas
merry christmas
in tier 2 oxfordshire tier 4 awaits
tomorrow people can still form a
christmas bubble on boxing day
they'll be told to stay at home any
english tulip today
three pound a bunch and richard's flower
shop will have to stay closed
we brought a lot of tulip bulbs in to
grow for christmas
hoping there would be no lockdown
this will cause problems we've still got
them left to sell
so what else do we do but as the
government tries to save lives first
the pandemic curve is climbing and the
number of people testing positive in
england rose by 58 according to the
latest test and trace figures
separate statistics show that on the
week starting the 12th of december
around 1 in 85 had covered in england
compared to one in 95 the previous week
in northern ireland it was 1 in 180
in scotland 1 in 140. in wales there was
a steep rise
with one in 60 estimated to have kovid
19.
i think we've got more impatience now
than at the peak of the first wave and
that that shows so no sign of letting up
at all and actually the case rate around
here is rising
this is a degree of busyness that none
of us have ever seen before
really um and you know what with the
hospital getting increasingly full of
patients with covid
you know it's only a matter of time
really before we go over our capacity
right now
and with warnings a new variant could
account for half of uk
cases christmas won't be all that's lost
to covert
these restrictions were implemented so
late
we cannot do really anything for the new
years
we will see a peak of of infections then
hopefully
the latest march will help us to just
start going back to something relatively
normal
the rise in cases is partly down to more
testing but even a week ago
this is a christmas few expected and
it's what happens beyond december that
matters now
ally foreski sky news